[音楽]
プー
グー
[音楽]
皆さんこれぞザ
街先ですか
a 今街って引いてどんな風景創造しましたか
あなたはそこでいつもどんなことしてますか
私は街の中でちょっと他の生主に行ってるんです
それがこれ古いコーヒー
私は1億人たちに一杯どう
そういった声をかけてコーヒーを食べて配るのが密かな処理なんです
こうして
この日はともですのズームその軒先を借りました
あのバッグの中にはカードを仕掛ける
各が2つ
そして横暴が一つ入っていました
開くとこんな感じ
お盆の上には自分の台所から持ってきた
ホットな珈琲堂号おいて
コーヒーを入れます街の中で
ないとコナへの人が
うんっ
誰かこれはいいなと思ってますけど yahoo りしたいわけじゃないし
バーゲンセールでもないし振り子やってるやってる
たくさん声をかけるつもりもないんです
でも必ずこんな人が街にいます
そう効率にぱとろーずなんです
あなたの街にもいるでしょ
何やってるんですよねこの人は
なになってるんでしょうねって言う人が私に何やってるんですかって聞くんです
ここがカフじゃないんです古いコーヒーをやっています私はいろんな人に個仕入れて
固執するのが趣味なんですよ
変わってるねでもいっぱいもらって高価な
そういう会話が始まったらこっちのものです
ほらっ
いい風景でそう
コーヒーを手に取った人同士が話したりコーヒーを待ってる人同士が話したり
ちょっとした会話でいいんです私は知らない人と話すのが大好き
松の中で知らない人と話すことは社会に直接触れているような手触りがあります
その手触りの虜になりました
そして私を返して街が構造的になる私と町
私の人々金持ちそうな人にもりん房総の人にも男にも女にも分け隔てなく一杯の
コーヒーを渡す受け取らない定理だった
この関係こそが
手作りの好調マイ public
そんなものになるんじゃないかなって思ってます
この前かブリックを作れるって事にますますハマっていきまして
公園とか
線路罰とかオフィス街でもやったことあります
いろんなところでコーヒーを入れて
で渡す
ギブアンドテイクですもんね見返りがいつかあるかもしれませんね
そう言ってくれると思いますが間違ってます私はギブアンドテイクって言葉が大嫌い
自分で完結です私はギブすることが好きなんです
ふとに与えるさせてもらうって
結構贅沢なことなんです
ところで末の中でと言いましたが松ってどこのことか
ハッチを定義されていませんよね皆さんの中でも100人いれば100通りの街の姿が
あると思います
でも地面というのは月夜の一部
本当は誰のものにもならないパブリックなものですよね
その上に
おオーナーさんが私のビルですとか私の家ですとか言ってプライベートの建物を建てて
いく
瀬戸私たち通行人は
この建物はプライベートなものだから見ないだけよ
ファブリックなところだけは見ることが許されるこんな風にして歩いてないですよね
私たちが見ているもので
どの管轄誰の管轄か誰の物かわからないけど何となく見ているこの空間
この空間のことを私は街と
感じるようになりました
正確には
高い所に住んでいる人もいるししかしつです事をしてる人もいるかもしれません
いろんな人がいるけどあなたと末の話を振る物
誰かと街づくりについて考えようっていうとき私はこっちに住んでます
私を知ったで働いていますいろんな事情を
買って気に入っててもまとまりがつかないですよね
言語で言うと英語みたいなもの公用語だと思ってください
このゾーン園芸の女ってだいたい70度と言われています
この1回がメインに入ってきて理解がちょっと感じられる
地面もちょっと感じられるこの風景を私は誰かと
街のことを考えるとき
はいここに街がありますねその常に指し示すこともしています
このす前止めに入るあたり1回と地面がクロスする
ここをグランドレベルと私は呼んでいて
ここでしかできないことをここだからこそプライベートとパブリックの交差点だから
こそ
ここでできることここでしかできないことエキサイティングなことをたくさんあるん
です
こんな a 想像してみてください街の中に人口が1000人います
仙人いる街とたった100人近いな街があります
仙人いる町は人口が多いけれども街の中には
こうやって街に出てみると壁しかない塩トラフホールがレイズ
そんなものがイエティ続くだからつまんないから誰も末に出て行かない
そんな専任の松と
なんかいつも立ち寄る a ちょっとしたお店がある
花が咲いている
あの犬いつも寝てるなぁそんな風に目がそう明日はそうそうする
そんなちょっと楽しめる街がある
たった100人しか居な街と
どっちが豊かに感じるでしょ
この松を訪れたらもしかしたら100人の松の方が人口多いのかもしれないなって思う
かもしれませんよ
人口は絶対に減っていきます日本の全人口絶対これから減るんですけれど
減ったときどう暮らすか
こうやって
壁やエントランスホールやガレージしかない人が関わることができないしの松と
誰かがお食事しているこんにちはって挨拶する人偶然会えた
そんな人が行き交う生きたまずどんどんこれから
差が開いていくと思います
こんな言葉もあるんです
g city at アイレベルというサイトには1回は建物の10%程度ですが
彗星の政権は210%はそこで起きるんです
と
一回ってあなたのものかもしれませんプライベートかもしれません
ちょっと誰かの人生を作ってしまいます
まぁちょっと風景になっちゃうんですあなたがどんなにそれを嫌がってもね
なのでここでせなきゃいけないことたくさんあるんじゃないか知らん
そう思って私は
日本ではじめての1回作りの専門家木だろうと決めたんです
そんなときこんなお話をいただきました
つく55年のもと構造だったビル
91回で何あればいいから
このビルは隅田川のほど近くになっていまして彼はを利用した物流の拠点であったん
です
なので倉庫や工場が非常に多かったもともとに気にしている街じゃなかったんです
ですが
この15年20年で規制が顔されて
倉庫や北条が huge つに高層マンションへ方変わっていますどんどんどんどん
工場や倉庫がマンションに変わるつまり
ふとがくわーっと積み上がっていく暮らし分宮っと積み上がっていく
どんなにぎやかな街になったでそう
あれっ
倉庫や構造だった時の方がまだマシだったんじゃないですか
そんな寂しい街の風景になってしまったんです
せめてここに住んでいると暮らしている人の顔グラり
見えるほうがいいじゃないかなじゃないと不健康な切らせませんか
もう一つ健康といえば wa 長は
健康とはなんぞやということを貼っチリモン後にしているんです
肉体精神
それと全く同等の条件として
世界一福祉の状態にあるということを掲げています
どうもみなさん社会的複数の状態にもあります
健康ですか
そう聞かれて9秒夫婦れる人は少ないかもしれません
社会的不クスっていう言葉ちょっと耳慣れない言葉ですよね
でもこういうことでしょ
世界的つまり自分の居場所
居心地のいいところそれが
自分のプライベートなところだけではなくてどこかにある
行きつけのお店あいさつする友達
サークルなんでもいいでも自分が誰かの中に存在していること
それはビクターや精神の通路所私はないけれど一回作りをするんだったら誰かの社会的
福祉に貢献できるようなことできるんじゃないかと思ったんです
そのためには老若男女合わなくすべての人が自由にくつろげる
ふとの濃度性が発揮される
ズブや貨車が
自由にたようでそしてそれをできる
お互いがそんな風にできる
これってうんと性格のいい人だけができることだと思いますか
私はそう思ってないです
もので作れるんじゃないかって
そんな実験をしたのかちょっとこちら
先ほどのビルを期すたランドリーという
今朝手にしたんです
ちょっと中を一緒に見てみましょう
中はこんな感じ
すべきでそう
の好きすぎないでしょ
そこがポイントなんです文月すぎると賢抹茶
ダサい所へ行きたくないちょうどいいチューニングを
私はデザインの中で緻密に
探していったんです
ここはコーヒーを飲むん
奥には私がオフィスとして使っているなが作れがあります
喫茶ランドリーですから当然洗濯機そしてミシンやアイロンまであります
そして子供たちが遊んでいた気もするんですが
さてこの長机をあると生かしてくださいと言われました
か質疑で何をするんでしょ
頭の設定した私としてはここはコワーキングスペースみたいになるんじゃないかと思っ
てたんです
私もオフィスとして仕事をしますし誰かパソコンを持ってきた人が知らない人同士一つ
の机を囲むようになるんじゃないかと
そんな想像していたら
なんと端を作る
みんなでパンをこねる会場にしたいからこの机を貸してくださいって言われたんです
面白いですよね自分の想像を超える区
実は他人の子 s がないんです
そして彼女たちはパンを作りながら
なんと毛布一枚でプレイルームまで床に作っていたんです
こんなことをしてもいい店だと思われたことが私は嬉しかった
ミシンがあるなら店のイベントやるそう言って
ことはでもしないのに捨てないで買ってリーポスターを書いているとお母さんもいます
そして虫のイベント本当に行ったんです
イベントなんて一回もやったことないお母さんがあっ
男の人や子どもたちにも椅子の使い方を教えていました
コワーキングスペースになるかなと思ってた場所は相変わらずそうはならなかった
子どもたちのコワーキングスペースなるんですけどね
演奏会 a
地元の企業が勉強会に使ってくれる時もあります
電子ピアノをいたらあっという間に歌声喫茶です
このカーサが演奏を始めただけでこの世代の人たちが
昭通市て知っている童謡をみんなで歌い始めるんです
この世代の人です特有のリテラシーが発揮されています
そんなコーナーで10ヶ月経ったときに振り返ったらなんとこれ転じていい
こんなことやっていい
みんながやりたいと言ったことに100以上ものことを
喫茶ランドで実現していました
この200てちょっとちまう
私が喫茶ランドリーが企画して開催したイベントの一つも入っていないんです
全部お客さん
ここでだったらできそうそう思ってくれたんです
イベントなんかやってなくたっていいんです
ガーでもいない時もあります
普段はこんな感じミシンを使っている女性
その奥田男性が仕事の打ち合わせその奥ではくれ
リラックスしているお母さん
うつはいろんな種類の人いろんな洲4-1
みんなバラバラそしてバラバラ好きなことやっています
でもそれを右手認めながら市民しながらひとつの空間で許容し合っているんです
0歳から100歳まであまねく人々がここに来ます
あるし目の小ささ
やりたいないつかできたらなそう思っていることが実現する場所になっています
プロの店プロの店員
そう思ってませんからあくまで一個人として
してくれる人と接しています延々らしいコミュニケーションが誘発される場所になって
います
そんな生き生きとした個人の能動性が
1回で末の中で発揮する
表出するそんな世の中になったら
どんなに素敵なことでしょ
そう思っています
まず1回作りから始めませんか
1回作りそれは人が末の中にエール日常作るということです
どんな人がいたって建物閉じこもっているのはダメ
人が見える1回人が見える街を作っていく
それは
ふとが視認しながら
次に振る舞うつ中でたようでそれを貯蔵できることそんな環境に繋がるんじゃない
でしょうか
それは健康の条件であったり幸福の条件でもあります
そうふとの幸福や健康につながっていく
する二やがて世界の平和つながる
私は1回作りは
そう皆さんの1回あなたの末の風景は世界の平和と膣坐剤なんです
そのことが言いたくて今日ここにやってきました
聞いてくださってありがとうございます
[拍手]